[Musique]
maintenant j'espère qu'elle l'intérieur
des communautés autochtones humains ils
vont pouvoir voir que le bien vouloir du
fédéral et de toutes les provinces et là
que nous sommes là pour être partenaire
mais nous ne pouvons pas continuer d'y
être si ces barricades reste en place
voyez un extrait de la conférence de
presse d'hier premier ministre justin
trudeau kg a changé de ton en disant que
la patience avait atteint à ses limites
au pays que la main tendue ne donné lieu
qu'à un monologue
ils voulaient dialoguer en vous le savez
avec les premières nations pour tenter
une sortie de crise
mais la session en est tout autrement
des blocages sont toujours en cours sauf
à saint lambert où ça a été levé au
cours des dernières heures
j'en discute ce matin avec 1100 molène
dupuis militante et nous y chronicles à
espace autochtone bonjour merci d'être
là et adopter un tel niveau lan
chirurgien innu de la communauté
autochtone de pessamit
bonjour bonjour coup et comment vous les
voyez vous à ce moment ci la sortie de
crise juste être doux l'a mentionné hier
il remet sentent les mains de du
leadership et des nations autochtones
en fait moi je pense que c'est encore
dans ses mains je pense qu'il ya encore
des choses que je vois me peut faire le
peuple et nation au dessus et à nos
demandes et des chutes à son avis deux
choses que la grc se retire de leurs
terres et deuxième main qu'on fasse un
moratoire qu'on a rappelé les travaux et
qu'on discute
la deuxième console n'a pas été remplie
je pense qu'ils ont un contrat de
travail à faire c'est sûr que le dard et
il fonctionne de l'oléoduc ses poteries
fédération aussi le provincial même en
province a dû également britanniques un
rôle à jouer et je pense qu'il faut
peut-être mais les lire les ruches et
autochtone de 40 chefs bellegarde
devrait faire partie de cette mission le
jeu parce que
il ya encore des choses à faire pour
sortir de la crise les chefs militaires
et certaines qui ont accordé une
conférence de presse hier en rappelant
leur condition pour pouvoir parler avec
le fédéral en rappelant comme vous
l'avez dit docteur volant de dire il
faut que la grc sorte de notre
territoire mais il faut également
interrompre tous les travaux du gazoduc
à ce moment là on serait prêt à parler
on sera prêt à dialoguer avec le fédéral
vous voyez c'est de quelle façon vous de
votre côté
eliane dont on était en train de marcher
justement dans la rue pour pouvoir
continuer de faire avancer la discussion
puis on a appris justement le discours
de monsieur trudeau et si on était moi
j'étais mis à terre par le fait qu'on
dirait qui a abandonné son leadership il
ya décidé de laisser les programmations
de se débrouiller
bien qu'on arrive à la fin des dialogues
avec les premières nations qui parle
encore continuer de discuter c'est
vraiment dire je préférais pas m'en
occuper et malheureusement on voit que
c'est la pression beaucoup de
l'industrie qui vient faire sauter dans
le cas de jodi lyn rigole ça a été
l'industrie comme une impression le
présentement c'est le gazoduc et là on
apprend en plus que dans certains des
permis des costauds gaceline qu il
manque des approbations de la
colombie-britannique pour pouvoir faire
passer donc il faut même forcer mes
fonctions alors qu'ils n'ont pas tous
les permis nécessaires
j'ai envie de découvrir ça hier donc
c'est certain que là on voit vraiment au
fond sans même avoir le droit de son
côté en dix ans on a tous les permis il
n'ya pas les permis nécessaires au
provincial donc c'est vraiment dire on
voit qu'on est en train d'essayer de
nous ramener comment 90 à une situation
une impasse c'est quand 55 jours la
crise d'oka et c'était pendant l'été
imaginez le ccas jours c'est pendant
l'hiver ça ça dit qu'on n'est pas là
pour le plaisir de
de jolis on est là pour se faire
entendre et malheureusement moi je vois
un abandon complet de monsieur truc
gauche sur la question
on va s'en parlait d'ailleurs est ce
qu'il faut faire intervenir les
policiers dans quelques secondes mais
faut quand même rappeler qu' il n'y a
pas nécessairement consensus non plus du
côté des premières nations voix des
conseils de bande qui ont accepté pour
plusieurs ce gazoduc en colombie
britannique que chez les chefs
héréditaire de watsu et m
également on voit qu'il ya division mon
collègue philippe leblanc a rencontré
une matriarche hier qui se dit chef
héréditaire aussi des watts ou athènes
et qui dit moi je pense faveur du tout
des manifestations je suis pas de leur
côté je reçois de l'intimidation
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans ce temps là du
côté fédéral d'intervalle ans qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour trouver le bon
intervenant à qui parler pour dénouer la
crise
le fait que la population soit
hétérogènes apple sans canadienne était
hétérogène aussi l'échec qui vote
conservateur d'autres libéraux les
autochtones sont pas monolithiques 1055
nations autochtones au canada et dans
chaque nation il ya des différences
internations donc on est c'est très
hétérogène ya des gens qui sont modérés
d'autres sont plus radicaux et la même
entre les chefs héréditaire ou être
souhaitait aussi là pour la
revendication territoriale absolument
puis je pense à représente un peu le
litre de façon hétérogène de palpation
effet à travers le monde et moi je pense
que ça vaudrait la peine
peut-être faire un ils sont 4000 watts
sous le thème de la population de
washington m 4000 peut-être que lors
d'une sortie de crise sur têt genk est
un référendum pour savoir c'est quoi le
point de vue de chaque personne et je
pense que les
- universal autochtones canadiennes il
ya plusieurs points de vue moi je t'aime
modéré moi j'ai vécu de l'accusé 90
j'avais 25 ans j'étais à montréal et en
chirurgie et j'ai vécu le racisme à tous
les jours j'ai dû me battre
j'essaye même quitté de pays en 90 je
pensais mais xavier en europe pour finir
mes études de chirurgie et j'ai part que
la crise dégénère aujourd'hui est que
mes enfants a pris un peu le prix
subissent le même récit que j'ai su bien
90 donc absolument que ça et jusqu'où
parce qu'on sent la pression quand même
premier ministre hugo qui a dit et pas
question d'envoyer l'armée
mais les provinces devraient quand même
faire appliquer les injonctions donc les
policiers manceaux policière je pense
que c'est pas la solution non parce
qu'il faut qu'il ya encore des
négociations faut que le leadership
politique camédia autochtone 100 miles
c'est important on est à money moyens
d'une grande une grave crise je pense
qu'il faut intervenir aujourd'hui une
évolution importante de la population
canadienne mon 90 et avait beaucoup de
racisme de méconnaissance des premières
nations
aujourd'hui d'amonier travailler
plusieurs personnes qui sont encore pony
qui sont ici sont d'accord avec les
positions qui sont sur la table mais
jusqu'où ça va tenir
on risque de perdre tout le travail
qu'on a faites dorer les derniers 20
printemps et que la réconciliation soit
je parle quelque chose du passé puisque
vous avez également les inquiétudes
oui je vous parle d'un chef héréditaire
des chefs de gang
moi je continue dit il faut pas oublier
non plus que des chiffres et du tas qui
sont des chefs de bande
la loi sur les indiens a été créé pour
avoir un chiffre qui parle pour tous les
indiens c'était vraiment une manière de
gérer facilement un grand groupe
mais j'essaye de montrer l'exemple en
velin web souhaitant c'est comme si on
dit on va faire des projets sur la côte
nord qui ont demandé l'autorisation au
maire de baie comeau passer un projet
traverse est il donc elle même pas la
juridiction pour la fin mais c'est
tellement plus facile dans l'historique
mais dans la panse et puis comment le
canada a créé les réserves de dire que
c'est dans la préparation de quelques
chefs et ont fait passer le gazoduc
il faut pas oublier aussi que dans
certaines des ententes il ya des clauses
de non divulgué
santé des clauses de ce qu'ils disent
mais au meilleur de vos capacités vous à
les décourager les membres de vos
communautés de se poser sur les médias
sociaux dans la vie par rapport au
projet donc nous on en compterait qui
existent pour certains projets et là en
plus moi je lis les commentaires en
ligne
et là il ya des groupes citoyens qui
disent on va foncer là dedans on va
l'aider faire des barricades ont
progressé des roues avec avec des
indiens sera jamais si on a quelqu'un
qui se pose est de s'occuper de la
relation parce que c'est une capacité
fait d'erreur et qui abandonne son au
provincial qui peu pauvre de travailler
sur cette juridiction le et le
conduiront vers polar mais ce n'est pas
le rôle de l'armée mais on veut
militariser la grc qu'une historique
problématique avec les premières nations
parce qu'ils ont fait les premiers
déplacements forcés des programmations
ayons pris les enfants les envies dans
les pensionnats et l'on a vu qu'ils sont
rentrés avec des chiens avec des fusils
avec des snipers pour déloger des femmes
qui étaient sur le territoire qui est
possédée donc c'est à eux et ça fait
milan qui sont là et là on les prend on
les déplace et tout de suite après son
industrie qui arrive qui démantèle le
campement donc c'est ça manque vraiment
que le gouvernement présentement au pas
la main sur l'épaule des profanations
mais à la main sur l'épaule de
l'industrie et ça si c'est la relation
la plus importante pour eux je pense
qu'ils ont vraiment laissé tomber cette
fois ci donc la conférence de presse de
justin trudeau ça fait monter votre
inquiétude d'un cran ou de plusieurs
crans la wii moi je regardais par le pam
à qui ce passe d'un coup ici c'est sûr
que nous on s'est fait dire la
réconciliation on ya cru on en a
commencé des négociations d'essayer de
développer de l'économie avec le canada
au québec
et là des choses comme ça arrive c'est
que ça manque vraiment que euro s'est
encore fait environ 150 ans plus tard
après toutes les promesses les traités
qui ont été pas écouté ou pas respecté
c'est inquiétant fait que je pense que
maintenant les impacts sur l'économie
sont majeurs à travers le pays qu'est ce
que vous en dites de sa lettre en volant
je pense que c'est ça des impacts sur
nous ça va impacter sur les peuples de
par ma nation éventuellement c'est plus
de propane et je mange du poulet mais
aussi le chemin
dumain donc et peut-être un moyen de se
parler et d'abandonner ses parts égales
ou est ce que c'est la bonne façon de
revendiquer vous dit à justin trudeau a
obtempéré à faire en sorte que ce que
disent les ouates souhaité m ce soit
fait avec les conditions dans ses
fonctions minimales soient respectés il
peut ensuite discuter
brison libéré car discutons je pense
qu'un travail à faire de façon
importante on voit qu'il ya des pros
matic importante au niveau de la
gouvernance autochtone qui sont à régler
vous pourrez visiter la loi des indiens
c'est sûr parce que on voit quelqu'un
disparité entre le ce que le
gouvernement veut est-ce que les
premières nations veulent au niveau de
la gouvernance
ce que je comprends c'est que vous dites
non la balle est toujours dans le cas de
justin trudeau peloton se faire poser
compte des droits humains en manque de
respect des droits humains des étagères
de bouteilles de ketchup puis de crème
glacée
on dit oui mais le chlore pour purifier
l'eau dans les villes
si on parle de communauté aussi qu'ils
ont même pas l'eau potable
à chaque fois on est très perdants parce
que au confort de l'ain on oppose
l'injustice que heroes de vie donc ça
montre un peu comment nous on est
perdant d'avancé si on va pas mourir
dans un coin au dérange d'économies mais
il ya 180 3 au canada y avait une
économie qui s'appelait l esclavage qui
était acceptable tout le monde avec un
ami l'économie va s'effondrer mais on a
enlevé des économies et juste comme
celle là où comme les gazoducs et les
économies c'est très bien remis mais il
faut arrêter de faire des économies et
je suis faut arrêter de mettre ça sur le
dos des droits humains de certains
citoyens canadiens avaient l'impression
que ça va durer longtemps car en
terminant docteur voilà je souhaite que
ça dure le moins longtemps possible
j'espère que li lé leadership canadien
autochtone provinciales vont se
rencontrer parce que de la cause
autochtone c'est pas juste et fédéral
ville et province doit intervenir aussi
tout le monde doit se parler pour le
bien-être de tous nos enfants
peu importe leur couleur leur religion
leur couleur
leur culture je pense que c'est pour le
bien de l'ensemble de notre population
parlons nous pour améliorer le sort de
tout le monde
deux personnes les volants récemment
lundi puis merci beaucoup de nous voir
ce matin me fasse bien